- So I already got all kinds of fan mail.
Not fan mail, but kinds of...
Fans that watch your thing.
- [Mark] Oh yeah, you have people
that watched your video.
Put that on your back.
- Yeah, fine. What are we doing?
- [Mark] I don't know, just talking
about the story of your life.
- Okay.
(indistinct)
We've got to get rid of all this.
- [Mark] All the bags?
- Mm-hm, everything, yeah, all
the stuff today. Thank you.
Okay.
- Hold on one second.
- [Ruby] What has been
going on in my life?
- [Mark] Ruby, you seem so,
like, together and intelligent.
The way you speak, the way
you are aware of things,
and yet you're living on the
street like a crazy person.
- Yeah, I am.
- [Mark] So I have a
hard time kind of coming-
- Look at all these diamonds.
I think of stuff like this all day long.
- [Mark] Where were you 10, 15 years ago?
Probably at home raising your kids?
- Yeah. Yeah.
- [Mark] Living a normal life in suburbia?
- But like, I was always a drug addict.
But the judge said that
I could get the kids back
because he believes that I can change,
and I said whenever the time's
right that I can change,
then I will.
- There's a lot of us
that believe in change no matter what.
- And I believe that truly, because, like,
my children, I know
they're missing me a lot,
but I can't have them here with me.
There's no way in hell.
- Do you ever see your kids?
- There's no way in
hell, you see how they...
It's crazy out there.
Anyways, I just said,
do what you got to do,
and now when my dad took
my babies out of my mom,
my dad knew, 1987, they
were gonna start doing this.
- Start doing what?
- Whatever's going on.
Whatever kind of witchcraft,
I don't know what to call
it now at this point.
- [Mark] Well, I mean, so. (sighs)
- And I'm not a filthy person.
It's 'cause I'm outside and I do my job.
- [Mark] And you're working all the time.
- And I work.
- Yeah, you're one of a few people that-
- And I'm in the filth, but
look what I come up with.
Like, people do this for me,
and it's so amazing, like, I
couldn't ask for anything more.
But as I'm going through this,
I miss my family tremendously.
- [Mark] I mean, so back to
your life before you ended up-
- I played sports in high school.
- [Mark] But were you-
- I graduated six months
early before my class.
- [Mark] You were smart, I can tell that.
- I wasn't very smart, I was
very stupid at that time.
- No, but I can tell-
- I was slow.
- [Mark] You're very
aware and intelligent.
- Okay, that's when I was younger.
Whenever I got like in my high school,
I was having problems
with reading and stuff.
I taught myself over the years
how to read faster and stuff
and how to put things together
if something was wrong,
you know what I'm saying?
Like...
Like through, I'd say, 6th grade,
to, but I don't remember
none of my young...
Young life, really I don't.
That's like a blur.
Like 4th grade I can remember my teachers,
I can remember a little
bit, this and that,
but I don't remember everything.
- You grew up where?
- Garden Grove.
- [Mark] Garden Grove, so Sun
River Valley, Orange County?
- Orange County, yeah.
- And your childhood was good?
- Great.
- [Mark] Nothing crazy happened?
- Yeah, but it was nothing
that wasn't normal.
I wasn't that smart.
My mom, like, I was always
in and out of restaurants.
My dad, he worked at a
restaurant, my stepdad.
So he met my mom whenever I was, like,
pregnant in her stomach,
he's a Mexican from Sinaloa.
He wasn't from Sinaloa,
yeah, he was from Sinaloa.
- So he's in the Mexican Mafia?
- Yeah, no, then my dad, no, he wasn't.
And my grandmother, no, my
grandmother, my grandmother,
my grandmother and all those family, no,
they're not, they're ranchers out there.
How I met the Mexican Mafia
is because at 15 years old
I met my street dad, and
he was Mexican Mafia.
- [Mark] Oh, that's who
you were talking about.
- Yeah, so my dad, he
was like into bullfights,
my other dad, and shit
like that, like real stuff.
Now, I don't know,
but yeah, I don't know how this came...
- [Mark] You started
using drugs at what age?
- Not till I was 18.
- [Mark] But you had kids later on, right?
- Yeah, 18.
- [Mark] So you had kids
when you were using drugs?
- No, I was using...
Yeah, maybe I just started
using when I got pregnant
with my daughter, but I didn't stop,
but I'd only used like two times
while I was pregnant with her.
- What was your drug then?
- Meth.
- Crystal meth.
- Yeah, but it wasn't,
weed was my thing then.
- [Mark] And what are you using today?
- Nothing, whatever I
use, it doesn't matter.
Everybody else is out there.
- [Mark] But you're using drugs today?
- Sometimes, yeah.
- Yeah?
- Yeah, because I have to,
just to cope with all
the bullshit and the pain
and all kinds of stuff.
- What kind of pain?
- I don't know, that
was downstairs talking.
- [Mark] I'm sorry?
- Did you know I met God
the other day, though?
I don't know what to tell
you about that one, but-
- [Mark] When did things
go haywire in your life?
- When I met my husband.
- [Mark] And what kind of stuff happened?
- Mm.
I've just been distracted
by his family since then.
I didn't know his family,
I didn't know nobody.
I didn't know any of them but a couple,
just a mother and father, a
father of his, his father.
Yeah, that's when my shit went haywire.
He had just thought that he was gonna
take on and put whatever
he did, I don't care.
Whatever's real, I don't know.
But what I do is I fight for the people.
That's what I do, and I fought
for my people, number one.
What I heard is two years ago
they dropped them off a deck,
all of them.
I don't know if that's true.
I believe maybe it could've been.
I don't know, but I woke
them all up. (laughs)
I woke all those sonuvabitches up,
told them to get up out of
their graves and they did,
and I said, how'd you get out?
Did you crawl, what did you do?
They said they dug themselves out.
How the hell did they dig
themselves out of a coffin
I'll never know, but that
gate must've unlocked
and something must have
pushed on top of their coffin,
you know what I'm saying, and sure,
somebody had to help them up out of there,
but they got out of there,
and I don't know how,
but they did, and that's
the kind of people
I want you to start talking to,
is those kind of people
that I've woken up.
- [Mark] Ruby, what was your
best memory in your life?
- Mm.
My grandma.
My grandma and my mom,
just our bonds we had together.
I miss that a lot, yeah.
- [Mark] Is this the worst
point of your life right now?
- Mm.
- You seem happy.
Every time I see you, you seem, like,
in a good mood, you're cheery.
- I have to be, because I
could be a lot worse off.
Today I've seen, I've seen
so much shit in my lifetime
that I'm just grateful.
- Where do you sleep now?
- At my friend's house and in a tent,
outside tent, yeah.
- And where do you get money?
- I don't, I just do my thing,
but they take good care of me.
- Where do you eat?
- I get whenever it comes out here.
- [Mark] Some days you go without eating?
- No, because they have all
these places around here.
- Yeah, the free food.
- Yeah.
So I don't ever go without food.
Now if I want to eat the food, maybe not.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- I don't trust shit out there,
you know what I'm saying?
I really don't, but I
have to trust something,
you know what I'm saying, and
I do, and I trust whatever.
But like yeah, I have
hope, I have a lot of hope.
You read that one and I'll give
you one other book to read.
I've got so many of them
I don't know what to do.
Okay, this book, this is the big one.
Is that the big, no.
- You always bring me gifts.
- Yeah, but it's always worth it with you.
I like you a lot, whenever I
didn't see you for a while,
I kind of get scared.
- I go into town sometimes.
- I get a little uneasy,
but then I tell them that
they have to show you to me
or something of that sort,
so I know that you're okay,
'cause if not, I'll find
you, I'll do my best.
- [Mark] You've been
treated for mental illness
or psych meds or anything like that?
- Yeah, oh yeah, they
threw me in the hospital,
but it was my husband's boyfriend,
I mean my husband's family,
that they were all cops
up in the valley here, so
they were fucking busting me
left and right and not ever taking him in.
Here, try this phone,
tell me how you like it.
That's brand new, and I don't use phones
very often, so there you go.
- [Mark] Thank you for
the books and stuff.
- Yeah yeah yeah. Ooh, sorry.
- That's okay.
- Yeah, so that's it.
- [Mark] Do you currently
take your psych meds?
- Nope.
- No.
- I don't need them.
I'm straight as an ace.
I can get every point on point.
And once they tell me
that I fucked up real bad,
then let me know, but I didn't ever
intentionally mean to blow
my friend up over there,
but he came right back,
thank god, but still.
I just turned around and I
walked away and I didn't...
I don't remember if I dropped something.
I don't know, but some shit set off.
- [Mark] When's the last
time you saw your family?
Kids or anybody.
- A long time.
Like three years, 2 1/2 years.
- [Mark] They probably know
you're down here, right?
- [Ruby] I don't know, because when I went
to both of my aunts'
houses and my mom's house,
it was empty.
- Oh.
- [Ruby] So I don't want to talk about it.
- Okay.
- Yeah, but we're good.
But yeah, I have a good life.
I mean, with friends like you
that I can actually trust,
really, honestly, I know I have met you,
you were like a doctor, you were...
You were...
You would fix, like, surgical
doctor, that's what you do.
Face surgery, and I know
that, and I know that,
but you were out of...
It was Hollywood, North Hollywood.
No, was it...
It was North Hollywood, yeah, it was.
- [Mark] I don't think so.
- [Ruby] Yeah, that's where
I have seen you before,
in my picture.
- [Mark] I don't really
get up there very often.
- [Ruby] Okay, but you never did surgery?
- Never.
- Doctor.
- [Mark] I should've, but
I never did, never pursued.
- [Ruby] You got a brother that does it?
- [Mark] I got a sister
that kind of does it, yeah.
- [Ruby] Okay, no, no,
no, it had to be, well,
I know you're somewhere
up there with the doctor
or something like that.
- I'm just a photographer.
- Well, you're beautiful at it.
- [Mark] You are too.
- And I love you for
everything you do for me.
- I love you too, Ruby.
- Yes, sir.
- [Mark] Every time I see you, I smile.
- Me too.
- [Mark] I just want you
to be happy and healthy
and back with your kids and all that,
and I just don't know how-
- That's not gonna
happen, anything possible
until the world changes.
- Until the world changes?
- Mm-hm.
- [Mark] What needs to
change with the world?
- Till the world changes.
- [Mark] The world seems to be
changing a lot right, lately.
- Real bad, quick.
I've seen so much out
there, it'd blow your mind.
But I stay, like, I don't
let that get in my way.
I just tell them, like, well,
it ain't gonna be me today,
and that's all that I...
You know what I'm saying?
And I just keep on
going along with my day.
And, like, yeah, I'm not an easy person,
but I'm not a hard person,
but I've been through hell and back.
How I've lived, I'll never know.
- [Mark] I'd love to see who
you were 10, 15, 20 years ago.
- You can go back.
- [Mark] And I'd love to
see you go back there again.
- Yeah, I can allow you to go back.
- [Mark] Get close to that.
- You can go back and
review those records,
everybody else has,
pretty much, in schools.
So you can, that's what I like about you,
is because you would always
ask, you know what I'm saying?
That's such a good thing,
because I feel like everything's
been stripped from me.
They went all the way back
to where I used to live
in the hospital 24 hours
a day all the time,
I never would hardly go home
because I had asthma so bad,
and they would call this
an asthma thing or whatever
or a cancer thing, I don't
know what to believe anymore,
because I've seen a lot of those doctors
that were fucking in those
rooms with me that have came
out here, and why are
they in my life like that?
I'll never know.
So I don't know what year
or what age this started
or when they started doing
this, but I want to say
it was just five years
ago, but now I don't know.
You know, I really don't know.
- Are you confused?
- Yeah, why do I have dogs coming out,
what the fucking shit is this?
Weird shit, ghost shit,
where I see, like, I call for an angel,
and he brings God of
fucking football angel,
and I'm just like, where
does that come from?
You know what I'm saying,
but I'm grateful for it.
- [Mark] What troubles you the most?
Are you afraid, are you confused?
- I haven't been able to lay still.
- Your mind's always moving?
- Just like, nothing in me,
just that ooh feeling,
you know what I'm saying?
That's what I miss, just
relaxing and not feeling nothing.
- [Mark] In this neighborhood,
that's impossible.
- No, just like, every
nerve in my body relaxed
and not something jumping
out just a little.
That's what bothers me the most lately,
but other than that, I'm good.
'Cause they haven't beat me,
they haven't beat nothing.
Ain't no internal
organs, they already did.
They hit the brain, brain's gone.
We already determined my brain's gone,
there's no way in hell
I could have a brain.
So I'm one of those people that
I don't know, it's just God.
God, and he knew what to
do, because he told me
these tinkers that were so
big, and I said how do you...
What the hell do you do?
I said, now I've had it,
I don't even want to know.
Turned out one way,
and the showed me how
they did it the other day,
and it was pretty neat,
but yeah, you know,
stuff like that, so they,
the lies, like, stacked.
Weirdest shit I've ever seen.
Whatever he says, I'm with him, you know?
But I love you, and I'll never stop.
I thank you for having
you here just sometimes,
you know what I'm saying?
Just that one little push
that I do have somebody
else, and you can have
two different friends, you can.
Who am I to say that you can't?
That's not me, but just, you know,
don't interfere with my life,
I'm never gonna interfere
with yours, and you can
always come and see me.
I don't care, but then there's some people
that I just don't ever
want to see in my life.
And I mean that, and I mean
that I'm gonna get you that back
and when I say that it's
not just me saying that.
I truly mean that, 'cause
if I can't have a life
or if I can't have my street
and somebody don't come up
that knows that I don't want them there,
they're not welcome there, you know?
And that's where it has went so far.
- [Mark] Okay, Ruby, thank you
so much for coming in again.
- Yes, sir.
- [Mark] Always lovely talking to you.
- Love talking to you too, yes sir.
- [Mark] Can I buy you some lunch today?
- Yes, please.
- You got it.
- Yes, sir.
- [Mark] Take this off you.
I still see these
glimmers of the old Ruby.
- [Ruby] Yeah you can,
you can go, and you can...